Sean great see you as always so so let's
just touch on those attacks I just
mentioned uh Brienne Belgrade that sort
of area as you say two Villages near the
briants region it's the branches well
North but the region actually is very
close to the Ukraine border they came
out of fire uh last night but also over
the last uh for the second time the last
10 days uh the Belgrade District came
under uh sustained uh fire uh we
understand that two people were killed
uh shebber Kino it was also under attack
there and that led to about two and a
half thousand people having to be
evacuated from that Village
um what's uh now traditionally these are
you know they're not a significant
tactical issue for Russia's deal with
but strategically it's creating a real
problem because there's a long border
here does Russia prioritize its limited
resources with protecting its borders
order as it move its people to the front
line uh with the war with Ukraine
knowing there's a counter-offensive
coming on that's creating a real problem
for Russia at the moment and touch on
the latest uh uh that we know about the
missile attacks from from Russia to to
Kiev in particular yeah it keeps an
interesting one because again Relentless
waves of attacks there's been 30 a
combination of missile and drone attacks
over the last 24 hours as ever the
drones slow speed Ukraine seem to be on
top of those uh the cruise missiles
which or the ballistic missiles are a
lot more difficult for Kiev to handle
but the multi-layer defense including
Patriot missile systems shown here does
seem to be taking out most if not all of
the missiles inevitably some of the
debris falls down that causes fires and
unfortunately some casualties as well
but the uh at the moment the defensive
umbrella seems to be holding up I mean
given that it is holding up and other
factors why do you think Russia
continues to try and Target Kiev from a
military perspective it doesn't seem to
make sense because what Russia rather
than wasting its limited resources on a
civilian Target it should actually be
targeting Ukraine's preparations for its
spring offensive there seemed to be two
reasons for for why they're doing that
first of all the Ukraine preparations
are likely mobile forces is and they're
quite well hidden so to do that you need
time sensitive Target capability which
is satellites looking down analysts
looking at it deciding what you're going
to use to prosecute the Target and then
attacking the Target that Loop requires
teamwork and coordination that is not
something that Russia is particularly
effective at doing at all the second
reason there seems to be that the
medieval war aims were to kill the
opponent's Army and then take their
Capital Putin has done exactly this he's
been fighting uh in in the cities and
actually now a particularly Bak moot but
it's also now reigning uh hell on on
Kiev but the challenge is he is not a
military guy and therefore he's not
keeping a ruthless focus on the military
AIMS in World War II there's an analogy
here that when Germany was trying to
invade Britain at the time they needed
to defeat the Royal Air Force they
took the Royal Air Force to the sword
and literally the Battle of Britain the
Royal Air Force is on its knees but for
some reason Hitler changed tack then he
suddenly because it turns out a city in
Germany was bombed in Anger he turned
the attention of the luftwaffe onto
bombing London now that gave the Royal
Air Force a breather yes it was bad for
londoners but didn't actually change the
outcome of the war and what we're
actually seeing I think is a similar
challenge for President Putin he is not
focused on the objectives of the war
he's anger angry over president
zielinski's temerity in attacking the
Kremlin and attacking across the border
and it's just demonstrating another
weakness of the Russian military machine